So I'm going to start with
something we actually discussed
at the very beginning of our class,
which is the idea of threat modeling and
developing a security mindset.
Which requires us to think like
the people who are going to attack us or
their adversary.
Now I know you've done some real
interesting work in this area.
>> Yes.
>> So
how does one think like the adversary?
Well first off I'd say it's almost
a guarantee to make you less popular
if you think like that, but you have to.
A lot involves getting into the head
of someone you think that would
have some purpose that's
counter to yours.
So if you're designing a system
you have to say well who would be
incentivized for a variety of
reasons to subvert that system?
And then try and anticipate who they are
and how resourced they are, what type of
capabilities they have, and then what
they could then, in turn, do to you.